je ne suis pas déguiser je suis loupé
des riders cup pourquoi parce que dans
moins de deux heures va se dérouler au
golf national de guyancourt note des
événements sportifs les plus importants
au monde la ryder cup la ryder cup c'est
une compétition de golf qui oppose les
européens et des américains et c'est à
la télévision le troisième événement le
plus regardé après la coupe du monde de
football et les jeux olympiques
voilà pourquoi en attendant cet
événement nous vous proposerons chaque
mois un magazine consacré au golf qui
s'adresse naturellement à ceux qui
pratiquent ce sport mais aussi à ceux
qui veulent le découvrir et ça s'appelle
par 78 euros
[Musique]
au sommaire de cette émission l'invité
arnaud courtier directeur général de la
fédération française de cyclisme la
découverte le golf de la boue dit celui
du racing club de france témoignage de
philippe françois après un grave
accident il s'est reconstruit grâce au
golf comment s'équiper dans le froid et
la pluie et enfin comme chaque mois le
conseil des champions
[Musique]
la vider de ce numéro 2 2 par 78 et un
sportif est ce un très bon golfeur mais
c'est surtout le directeur général de la
fédération française de cyclisme il
s'appelle ardo courtiers arnaud
courteille bonjour bonjour alors vous
êtes le directeur général de fédération
française de cyclisme quand tu vas
parler d'eux de golf mais d'abord de
vélo d'abord vous sortez d'un chauffeur
d'europe qui s'est déroulée au vélodrome
saint quentin qui a été un gros succès
gros succès populaire et plus gros
succès aussi pour les français oui un
gros succès à tous les niveaux un succès
d'abord organisationnel les équipes ont
livré un très bel événement on avait une
trentaine de pays européens présents
pour cette compétition les français ont
montré qu'ils étaient là la jeune
génération ceux qui sont déjà en pis
pour tout te 2020 des belles médailles
des médailles d'or des titres de
champion d'europe et ça c'est vraiment
pour nous à la plus belle réussite
des jeux olympiques il faut dire que
voilà les olympiques avaient pas été
tout à fait à la hauteur de vos
espérances oui les bus les jeux
olympiques de rio de nom de rio à la
hauteur des espérances mais si mon
travail de la pierre d'angle inquiète
donc on est attendu sur la prochaine or
malgré tout une très très bonne saison
pour les équipes de france dans toutes
les disciplines parce que quand on parle
de vélo et faut pas oublier qu'on parle
de route n'en parle aussi steve cross de
piste de bmx devait été on a des grands
champions et des grands champions en
devenir donc on a toutes les raisons
d'être confiant pour l'avenir alors
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
de rio mais si on regarde toute l'année
elle est très favorable aux équipes de
france et elle est très favorable nous
terminons l'année
premier au classement des médailles de
l'union européenne de cyclisme pour les
ans devant tout le monde tout simplement
c'est bien oui c'est bien alors ça fait
combien de temps que vous êtes directeur
lobry non ça va faire même ça fait deux
ans
le et le vélo est arrivé commandant
votre alors le vélo est arrivé dans ma
vie par une gauche contre que je dois au
golf je suis folle faire aussi j'avais
un plaisir de rencontrer un grand
cycliste en la personne de laurent
fignon ah oui et sympathiser avec lui
le plaisir et l'honneur de faire
quelques parcours de golf avec lui et
c'est ce qui m'a permis aussi de
découvrir le vélo simplement il ya une
rue qui était inaugurée à son nom dans
exactement pendant le championnat
d'europe avec le maire de montigny le
bretonneux président de saint quentin en
yvelines et valérie fignon la pub de
laurent nous avons inauguré la rue
laurent fignon puisque la fédération au
vélodrome et le siège est implanté aux
mains rue leurs amphis ça consiste en
quoi des directeurs généraux des
fédérations ça consiste à gérer tout ce
que je fais ça ne veulent pas faire il
plaisante bien sûr non ça consiste dans
la gestion globale de la fédération
comme une entreprise la partie comptable
la partie juridique la communication le
marketing l'organisation de tous les
événements ils sont très très nombreux
organisé par la fédération ou encadrés
par la fédération avec des organisateurs
privés donc on est une petite pme d'un
peu plus de 40 salariés qui toute
l'année s'attache à faire en sorte que
le vélo fonctionne en france tout est
fait pour qu aux décos
venir on s'inscrit au vélodrome
nationale sur site internet il ya des
baptêmes on vient on est encadré par un
pro c'est vraiment très très sécurisé et
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire et
l' avantage de la piste c'est qu'on
n'est pas embêté par la pluie on n'est
pas embêtés par les purs on est indoor
on peut le faire de jour de nuit on peut
le faire tout le temps et le golf alors
comme vous l'avez découvert un logo j'ai
découvert par hasard je suis pas du tout
issu d'une famille de golfeurs c'est au
lycée j'avais un camarade qui était un
golfeur amateur de haut niveau à
l'époque qui s'appelle fabrice tarnos ah
oui voilà il est devenu pro puis quand
j'ai ensuite un grand joueur et fabriqué
au golf et m'a fait découvrir ce sport
merveilleux qui ne m'a plus jamais
quittés vous avez beaucoup de bruit la
source que maintenant avec la
plus compliquée oui j'ai pas mal joué
mais effectivement aujourd'hui c'est
difficile mais j'essaye on n'est pas
loin du golf national j'essaie de temps
en temps de venir taper quelques balles
auxerre a un parcours avec des amis
ouais et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
vous apporte au fond le golfe 1 le goal
samatan peu comme le vélo ben oui il
ya des points communs le premier des
points communs entre le vélo et le golf
c'est que ce sont dans les deux cas le
sport d'une vie on peut commencer très
petit très jeunes et ont pratiqué très
longtemps il ya beaucoup de sport on
doit s'arrêter un certain âge le golf le
vélo qu'on peut continuer tout le temps
ça c'est merveilleux ça fait partie de
ces sports aussi où on peut recréer la
cellule familiale en dehors du foyer on
peut venir jouer en famille on peut
rouler en famille sans problème d'âge
parce qu'on fait ensemble et par contre
comme dans d'espoirs de solution donc ce
sont des belles valeurs et puis c'est
une évasion un parcours de golf c'est
magnifique qui sont tous différents
c'est une forme de tourisme quelque part
et ça c'est agréable et puis je crois
que c'est le seul endroit où j'ai éteint
mon téléphone portable c'est vrai ce
qu'on va faire maintenant si vous êtes
d'accord vous allez taper quelques
balles et puis sébastien risquer
un bon pro il va vous regarder que
peut-être sais que je vais très bien
mais peut-être qu'on peut quand même
améliorer d'autres retours très très
bien c'est relatif mais certainement des
choses à améliorer j'espère justement
qu'il va trouver qui va m'aider à
améliorer mon jeu
bon sébastien vous avez bien regardé le
seul garde au alors tout à fait d'un
stick ou non qui me disaient qu'ils
avaient des petits points de contact
parfois
cette difficulté à contrôler sa
trajectoire c'est vrai qu'au vu de son
swing on a pu se rendre compte
qu'effectivement il a un petit point de
posture de placement départ qui le garde
ne m'étais pas d'être stable pendant
tout le mouvement qui s'appelle les
genoux un petit peu en x ont narré carte
est un petit peu les genoux en lui
demandant qu'ils soient moins inclinés
vers l'avant simplement de manière à ce
qu'ils aient un peu plus de maintien et
de stabilité avec le bas du corps voilà
tout simplement ce qui lui a permis en
fait mon choix je pas forcément décrit
tout ça au moment où on est intervenue
mais est ce qui lui permet de décrire le
souhait salaires le déplacement latéral
excessifs qu'ils faisaient et du coup
qu'il appellerait d'améliorer la qualité
de son contact donc pas déjà ça a une
incidence directe sur la longueur qu'on
produit voilà on a un meilleur toucher
de balle également sur la direction
voilà tout ce temps en temps il avait
tendance à les en a peu talon pointe
avec une légère variation du club
revient pas de la médiocrité si on ne
retiendra les pétitions exactement voilà
donc en ajustant très peu de choses un
peu le manche du club à l'adresse qui
était un peu trop centrés qu'il fallait
replacer comme il doit l'être au départ
c'est à dire un tout petit peu incliné
vers l'avant pendant très légèrement
afin de respecter parfaitement le club
pour sa position neutre on arrive à
améliorer leurs résultats merci beaucoup
et sébastien grâce à vous la voirie va
descendre à un chiffre je prends cette
année j'espère je le souhaite en tout
cas ce n'est pas travailler dans ce sens
merci beaucoup c'est matière d'emploi
[Musique]
chaque mois par soixante dix huit vous
pouvez découvrir un golf des yvelines
pour ce numéro nous avons choisi un golf
mythique celui du racing club de france
le golf de la boulie tout près de
versailles alors je suis en compagnie de
jean paul goude est directeur du golf de
la folie et directeur général du racing
club de france et claude rosemère vous
êtes secrétaire général du racing club
de france membre depuis que votre
tout-petit 1
alors je vais vous parler avec vous
d'abord peut-être de ce racing là il
n'est in et commencer une affaire de
deux lycéens au début tout à fait le
racing club de france en fait a été
créée grâce à un groupe de lycéens du
lycée
condorcet condorcet à paris et qui
régulièrement s'entraîner au footing au
jogging entre lycée condorcet et la gare
saint lazare puis un jour ils ont décidé
d'aller un petit peu plus loin donc ils
ont pris un train de la gare
saint-lazare ils ont atterri à colombes
et de là il se retrouver un grand champ
de patates je dis j'en sais pas si c'est
vraiment c'était le gars est et c'est là
où le
stade yves du manoir de colombes à il
pleuvait grâce à ce groupe de lycéens je
dirais qu'ils sont en fait les créateurs
du racing club de france alors là on est
à la fin du 19ème à peu près
1882 exactement ça et le golf c'est il a
fêté ses cent temps il n'ya pas très
longtemps parce que c'est de 1901 exact
leur assène le golf du racing club de
france a été créé en 1901 il ne
s'appelait pas à l'époque russell de
paris gaulle de paris tout à fait donc
ce golf a été créé et le racing club de
france en a pris
on a pris la direction de la direction
ou la possession orienté en
1952 après la juste après la guerre car
il faut dire que pendant la guerre
l'occupation allemande le gold de paris
était occupé par les forces allemandes
comme c'était en fait devenu un terrain
d'entraînement destiné aux chars de
l'armée allemande donc pour
bâtir de tout ça donc il a fallu tout
refaire est on reconstruire enfin le
parcours de la vallée a été remodelé en
1952 parce qu'au niveau du goal de la
boulie dont nous avons trois parcours le
parcours de la vallée le 18 août
exactement le parcours de la forêt
qu'ils ont et date de
1967 et nous avons également un neuf
trous donc neuf par trois qui s'appelle
le coteau tout sa répartie sur notre
site qui fait 106 hectares et nous
abritons également à la boulie la
section hockey sur gazon il nous avons
également sept courts de tennis alors il
ya évidemment quand on feuillette par
exemple l'album des descentes en on voit
qu'ils allaient tous les plus grands
joueurs du monde sauf dû jouer ici dans
des compétitions il eu beaucoup de fun
de france une vingtaine je crois et puis
il ya uniqlo cu ballesteros et il était
d'ailleurs aux gamins oui effectivement
je me rappelle de tiger woods à la
boulie d'abord lorsqu'il est venu il a
découvert le parcours gelé suivi lors de
ces parties d'entraînement il avait déjà
à l'époque une certaine notoriété qui
commençait à il commence à dire c'était
un nom dans le monde du golf
et je dois dire que c'était
impressionnant car je me suis aperçu ce
jour là que notre parcours n'était plus
à la dimension de sa puissance et de son
talent car j'ai vu des coups de golf que
je ne reverrai sur l'ultime son parcours
de la bougie grave d'ailleurs pourtant
yann pourtant il ya des très grands
joueurs français notamment mais il ya
déjà le plus célèbre d'entre eux c'est
c'est thomas levet thomas levet mal mais
qui est un enfant du club c'est bien de
dire qui a été formé comme physiquement
au racing qui a fait toute sa carrière
amateur au racing club de france à la
boulie avant de passer professionnel et
s'est vu la ryder cup qui a joué la
ryder cup qui devait gagner la ryder cup
la vocation du racing club de france
c'est d'abord la détection des fonds
sportif la formation des jeunes sportifs
et après de l'effet de les faire
progresser
jusqu'au jour ils peuvent prendre leur
envol
pour des carrières sportives
évidemment c'est un club privé mais
au fond le public peut venir s'il veut
vendre les gens qui jouent au golf
peuvent venir jouer la semaine s'est
ouvert absolument vous pouvez jouer donc
les visiteurs peuvent venir jouer une
fille en semaine sans aucun problème le
week-end étant réservé à nos membres
est-ce que la ryder cup a déjà un impact
parmi les éléments parmi les gens qui
veulent jouer ou est ce que c'est encore
un peu tôt alors écoutez déjà un impact
bon là la ryder cup 2016 viennent se
terminer
il faut inciter les gens à découvrir ce
qu'est le golf les valeurs qui amène le
golf c'est un véritable
c'est plus qu'un sport mode de vie c'est
un sport qu'on peut pratiquer en famille
quel que soit son âge donc il ya
vraiment beaucoup de choses à découvrir
autour du golf la ryder cup reste du
très haut niveau alors bien évidemment
tous les tous les initiés ce sera un
rendez vous incontournable mais je pense
qu'il faut il faut amener à ce que le
plus de monde possible
sache ce que c'est que ce sport alors
nous l'avons vu déjà cette année avec
les jeux olympiques c'est un premier pas
je pense qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire et il faut peut-être
amené les enfants déjà depuis depuis
l'école
moi quand je faisais du sport très jeune
tout le monde jouer au handball voilà
aujourd'hui ici si le golf pouvait
devenir le handball l'époque ça serait
fantastique pour nous tous d'abord on va
croiser les doigts merci infiniment des
enfants que vous louvercy reflet du
manque le grenelle et puis alors longue
vie à ce magnifique magnifique club
c'est merci bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va tout de suite retrouvé le témoin
de cette émission c'est quelqu'un qui a
peint très grave accident s'est
reconstruit grâce au golf qui s'appelle
philippe conçoit philippe françois bon
joueur je suis ravi de vous recevoir
parce que c'est une expérience
extraordinaire dont nous allons parler
ensemble qui est de l'expérience de
reconstruction grâce au golf à la tout
commence par un événement terrible que
d'un accident extrêmement grave qui vous
est arrivé à comptait 2 est cet accident
merci patrice de m'accueillir pour cette
interview en effet bon cet accident
c'est comme tous les accidents des
événements imprévisibles des
circonstances qui s'enchaînent et qui
font que
l'être qu'on était qu avait un peu le
sentiment d'invulnérabilité du jour au
lendemain il est totalement détruit il
est totalement dans le coma il est
totalement avec des vertèbres brisées il
est transporté en hélicoptère depuis une
piste de ski d'un accident de ski c'est
un excellent skieur on le dit on le dit
j'ai beaucoup de ménages vis à vis de
moi j'ai une coupe j'ai gagné une coupe
dans un championnat voilà donc je me
débrouille à skis mec comme quoi c'est
pas parce qu'on pilote bien ses skis
qu'on n'est pas à l'abri d'un événement
n'a lieu le coma il ya eu le coma il ya
eu les opérations il ya eu les
ostéosynthèse et puis il ya eu surtout
la découverte que la moelle épinière est
abîmée que des faisceaux dans la moelle
épinière été lésés et ça ça s'est
réveillée brusquement et ça a changé
vraiment fondamentalement le cours de ma
vie et donc oui c'est à vous retrouver
avec nous titille un sportif qui était
voilà pendant la longue un corps qui ne
répond plus voilà encore un corps qui ne
répond plus j'avais démarré le golfe
voilà voilà
que moi alors je vais démarrer quelques
mois avant septembre 2008 et l'accident
a eu en février 2009 donc je peux pas
dire que
j'ai fait beaucoup de golf mais avant
dans mon histoire avant mais quand j'ai
commencé à ressurgir et à revenir dans
ce monde des humains la séquence assez
assez très concrètement il ya trois
quatre ans quatre ans après l'accident
quatre en quatre ans après l'accident
quatre ans après l'accident pendant
quatre ans ça a été très dur très
difficile très douloureux je me suis dit
bon la marche me fera du bien le grand
air
[Musique]
et puis fonctionnellement j'avais besoin
de retrouver quelque chose bon et puis
j'ai un ami qui est médecin qui m'a dit
mais philippe tu fais du golfe et je
vois que ça va mieux donc essaye de
réfléchir pourquoi ça va mieux pourquoi
ça va mieux effectivement je me suis
j'ai investiguer le sujet je me suis
rendu compte que des études avaient été
produits sur les bienfaits du golf en
matière fonctionnel en matière de santé
je me suis dit mais au fond voilà
quelque chose qui m'intéresse je suis le
témoin en actions et de la marche de
quelque chose que je lis et que je fais
et ça je me suis dit il ya quelque chose
à faire c'est un challenge que je me
suis donné un projet passion qui s'est
créé de dire ben le golf et la santé il
ya un lien je vais l'explorer dont j'ai
eu beaucoup de contacts sur sur ce sujet
avait créé avec des médecins avec des
médecins notamment un laboratoire inserm
qui est basée à la faculté des sciences
faculté de médecine à montigny donc sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin mais
qu'est-ce que savoura a porté sur votre
connaissance du corps et peut-être sur
le fait de moins souffrir
d'accepter peut-être parfois la
souffrance alors la souffrance la
douleur c'est effectivement un des
grands problèmes que j'ai puisque je
suis affecté par des ce qu'on appelle
les douleurs chroniques et le fait de
s'engager dans une activité qui est qui
demande du temps c'est à dire on marche
pendant plusieurs heures il ya une
nécessité d'un entraînement intense le
golf c'est un sport quand même
relativement ingrat l'apprentissage est
dur et long pour un résultat qui est
parfois est aléatoire bon donc il faut
accepter cette ses dimensions et le fait
à dose dépendant de s'impliquer dans de
l'entraînement dans de la marge dans des
parcours quand il fait froid
quand il quand il pleut alors qu'on sait
qu'on va souffrir ça constitue un
remaniement du cortex qui fait qu'on est
capable de saison on change le cerveau
se remanie on parle de dé capacité
inouïe du cerveau à se remanier les
neurones qui se reconstruit ça moi je le
vis en ce moment je le sens et
pardon se lever pour très concrètement
il me semble que vous aviez racontée par
exemple quand vous marchez vous avez des
brûlures et à cause du froid le pantalon
et instruments il s'appelle des halles
houdini en médicalement oui et alors
comment surmonter vous avez surmonté ça
ben on le 6 on peut on le surmonte c'est
à dire qu'on apprend à gérer la
situation de la douleur on apprend
par ce que les médecins appellent
l'habituation c'est à dire la capacité
au cortex de pouvoir intégrer de
nouvelles somesthésiques en quelque
sorte de nouvelles nouvelles sensations
à apprendre que son corps évolue alors
ça prend beaucoup de temps on peut
l'apprivoiser je me suis dit j'ai deux
solutions soit je reste dans mon
fauteuil chez moi et je l'apprends
ivresse pas soit je vais là je sois j'y
vais je vais l'apprivoiser savait
difficile mais j'ai du résultat
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
je suis capable de faire un parcours de
18 trous sans trop souffrir donc vous
avez créé alors j'ai créé intéressante
et voilà j'ai créé cette association
golf et santé avec ce médecin américain
qui est qui est un ami
pour la recherche médicale c'est ça hein
pour travailler sur la recherche
médicale dans différents dans différents
domaines en m'appuyant sur la question
du mécénat de telle façon qu'on puisse
mesurer en quoi la pratique du golf à
porte sur la santé à certain nombre
d'indicateurs et montre que le golf a
des vertus matière immunitaire matière
cardiovasculaire en matière pénale
faites donc il ya des recherches qui ont
été faits à l'étranger ouais je ne vois
pas pourquoi on ne fait pas on les
ferait pas chez nous mais bon et donc je
me suis fait on allait chercher en a les
golfeurs il faut simplement les faire
fructifier les faits remettre ensemble
et un travail d'assemblage c'est la
mission je me suis donné merci beaucoup
aux fribourgeois merci patrice
il fait pas toujours beau même quand on
joue au golf alors comment jouer quand
le pont n'est pas avec vous c'est ce
qu'on va voir tout de suite avec
sébastien russe y est c'est le moment de
notre partie technique va parler du
matériel et comment je me quand il fait
froid quand on est déjà au mois de
novembre arrive et la fin de l'année ce
n'est pas la période préférée peut-être
pour les golfeurs mais sébastien russie
on peut jouer toute l'année comme un but
tout le faire
les îles britanniques ont joué toute
l'année important le climat est un peu
moins clément qui si elle s'impose
absolument aucun problème simplement
s'équiper convenablement voilà c'est ça
qu'on va parler comment commencer qui
viennent aussi vite déjà un un pull qui
est déjà qui est fait pour ça alors
c'est ouais c'est ce qu'on appelle un
windstopper donc c'est un pull en laine
avec une membrane à l'intérieur mais
vitaux vendre passé voilà donc souvent
on est bien c'est un coup mais bon on
est très bien à l'intérieur voilà donc
ça c'est une des choses qu'on peut avoir
il faut essayer de porter également des
vêtements assez plat du corps
faut éviter d'avoir des chansons plutôt
assez près du corps et une rouge et non
pas dans vos amplitude donc quand on
avait ce qu'il faut vérifier pour soit
pas gênée quand on fait y compris ces
jeux c'est une des premières choses
ensuite pour l'hiver on a besoin d'eux
d'éléments incontournables tels que des
chaussures étanches voilà il ya des
modules étaient hiver il faut plutôt
opté pour des modèles hiver plutôt
gore-tex quand même pour être sûr que sa
place par voilà nous ça me passe pas est
également une bonne tenue plus votre dd
pile comme ceux sur moi voilà donc qui
comprend marimbas et en eau de pluie
comme vous le constatez
laquelle on n'est pas du tout gênée pour
jouer et qui est en gore-tex passé cinq
heures sous la pluie en restant au sec
65 s'échouer ces espaces est impliqué
savès ni passé la pluie ni le vent il
vaut mieux investir dans un produit de
qualité qui te met un petit bleu plus
cher mais on bat ça va permettre de le
conserver beaucoup plus longtemps en
fait il résistera beaucoup mieux voilà
après le sac il parapluie évidemment ces
dames ont le parapluie c'est également
le bonnet important parce que l'endroit
on perd le plus de chaleur passé par la
tête en fait donc faut bien pour ça
squeeze la tête et les pieds c'est
exactement donc faut y penser voilà avec
un petit bonnet on peut également avoir
des gants d'hiver il faut compter
plusieurs grandes équipes le alors quand
il pleut ouais moi ce que je fasse ce
que j'en prends plusieurs donc je vais
en avoir deux trois paires de gants au
cas où il ya un peu d'humidité 40 10
parce que quand on va prendre le club et
qu'on va taper notre coup comme on n'a
pas le droit d'être abritées par un
parapluie dans les règles de golf
forcément à prendre il va se modifier
progressivement donc se fait en général
c'est que
j'ai donc un cover bague comme vous
pouvez le voir sur mon sac donc c'est
cette eau ou ce qu'on va positionner sur
le dessus du sac avec des fermetures
éclair c'est assez pratique si vous
sortez votre club vous le prenez vous
jouez votre coup
c'est complètement étant je ne ferai pas
passer l'eau donc vous gonfle seront pas
mouillé fera tout ce qui est dans votre
sac sera pas mouillé quoi exactement est
bien donc voila mais fausse équipe et
puis j'ai même ça ainsi on a très très
froid si on est frileux alors 4 froid
extrême mais c'est pas mal ça rend
possible regardez le le golf pour tapé
do sul est pas obligé de l'enlever on
met les moufles
ouais et en fait on peut carrément
l'accroché comme ceux ci tout ça voilà
on le met dessus dès qu'on enlève loch
lomond des chariots on tape son
couronnement
ça donne encore un peu plus de confort
en hiver donc on peut jouer partout des
temps à condition d'être bien équipé
tout
merci beaucoup c'est va terrifier mal
aux oreilles
ce mois ci pour notre rubrique l'astuce
de champion nous accueillons une
championne française gwladys nocera
bonjour jean patrice cette balle gady
salaire toute simple elle est près du
green chip en montée mais
systématiquement c'est une approche à
gratter
c'est vrai que souvent on a tendance à
gratter ce coup pour moi l'essentiel
c'est vraiment de regarder la quantité
d'herbe qu'il ya là j'en ai pas trop
mais j'en ai beaucoup derrière la balle
faut que je fasse attention de ne pas
décéléré dans au moment de l'impact et
surtout de ne pas la prendre en cuillère
donc ce que je vais faire c'est que je
vais m'appuyer un petit peu à gauche
garder les mains très solides à l'impact
et accélérer dans la bataille
on est parfait les données ouais c'est
bien alors en résumé en résumé surtout
bien regarder comment est placé la balle
dans le rough et le rough obligé à
garder les mains très solides à l'impact
garder une phase de clubs ouverte au
maximum et ne surtout pas ici de
l'apprendre en cuillère puisque de toute
manière le sandwich est créé pour faire
voler la balle c'est pour ça que vous
avez choisi un sandwich voilà donc moi
typiquement ce genre de type que je joue
pour rentrer parce que parce que c'est
d'être finalement qui sont relativement
simples à condition de garder les mains
solides et d'accélérer dans la balle
pour cette année je vous souhaite à tous
de plus faire de gratte et à toi bien 10
d'emboîter après qu'un maximum
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]